single Lala is back what can we expect
out of her a lot of awkward moments with
dukes because I apparently just don't
know how to flirt anymore I've gotten a
lot better
um and you get to see the guy that I
sleep with for the first time since my
relationship I mean I've never in my
life had like silver sex with some like
random guy so you get to see that you're
welcome okay well tell us more who is
this random guy you know what I kind of
he like took a piece of my heart when we
like decided to part way so I'm really
excited for you guys to see him and yeah
it was great I'm so excited to see that
I'm so happy to see a smile on your face
because through the headlines I can only
imagine what you've been going through
what has that been like for you how are
you doing you know what I feel like I
have not even had time to process how
I'm doing or what's going on in my world
because I have a baby who I wasn't
allowed to really skip a beat I think
when I have resolution I'll be able to
sit down and really process what went on
but right now you know I'm just trying
to practice gratitude every single day
and also you know I'm in Mama Bear mode
so that's where we're at
in that Mama Bear mode you said that you
just needed to get it off your chest and
you told Raquel the truth about you and
James why was that so important to you
to tell in this season
oh you know this season was very strange
for me it was like I really leaned into
my program
when everything went South in my world
and it was just like I don't want
skeletons in my closet I want to be
forthcoming I want to put my ninth step
into place and and just really do things
differently now I don't know how she
felt about it after I told her I don't
know if I should have told her but I'm
glad it came from me rather than someone
else I bought as well I talked to her
about it tonight she said It felt a
little manipulative and controlled do
you agree with that those are such big
words for her to use I'm shocked that
she would come up with such big words so
it's not coming from a place of jealousy
by any means there's no Auto World where
you and James are ending up together no
there's no version of that
very good I was also pulled back by your
fight with Schwartz back here he really
attacked your appearance as a woman how
did you feel about that you know I love
schwartzy
um I have to have a lot of respect for
people to care about their opinion of me
and I don't think I have much of that
for him so I was I was a little
unaffected by it I was shocked at what
he was saying but it's not like I
carried it with me for too long I'm also
really excited I was listening to your
podcast and I completely agree with you
it's back to the OG Vanderpump Rules if
people are back in apartments people are
back to single what was it like being on
set and filming back to like the
original days it felt really good I felt
like I was in my element like people who
even if we're not connecting these
people are like my La family and I
really do have love for them in a very
very unique and strange way that most
people wouldn't understand but it just
felt good I felt like we were back to
the roots of why this show was made a
success from the very beginning very
last question obviously we talked about
the headlines with Randall right now
what is your hope moving forward for
your daughter
um my hope is just to protect her at all
costs and that's what I am working on
every day and I won't stop until I can
ensure that her future and her
well-being are safe